pour ce conseil d'installation c'est guy
malandain doyen de l'assemblée qui a
présidé la séance pour élire son
successeur après un vote à bulletin
secret sans surprise c'est à les rabais
qui devient officiellement maire de
trappes 28 votes contre 11 pour son
adversaire
othman nasco mon équipe est déjà au
travail
je dors peu mais je suis fière et ravie
et honorée d'avoir été choisie par les
trappistes pour être leur mère nous
avons pris immédiatement des décisions
importantes pour préparer notamment la
rentrée scolaire le passage à la semaine
de quatre jours
fière d'annoncer aux trappistes voit une
première promesse tenue
on conseille quelque peu agitée à
l'image d'une campagne difficile
al'annonce de l'élection de son
successeur guy malandain quitte la salle
après avoir occupé le siège de premier
magistrat de la ville pendant 19 ans je
suis content que je pourrais servir les
habitants même dans une fonction
d'opposition je le ferai le dos pas
d'opposition systématique si si c'est si
c'est bien c'est bien croire je suis pas
je suis pas un fou pour les politicards
qui dit non par principe à tout ce que
les autres décident on met à écrire la
discorde entre les deux listes la gauche
unie pour que tu rappes respire d'al
hira b et engagement trappe citoyen
d'hotman natrue le nouveau maire
souhaite un terrain d'entente afin de
travailler sereinement avec l'opposition
j'aurai un dialogue respectueux avec
l'opposition
je les invitais d'ailleurs à quitter les
postures d'opposition de principe et à
rentrer dans une dynamique de
propositions j'attends des actes pas des
déclarations d'intention les méthodes de
campagne qui qui ont eu lieu que chacun
a pu voir - ont profondément inquiété et
me laisse penser que les déclarations
d'aujourd'hui ne seront pas forcément
suivies de faits mais si c'est le cas
nous serons comme nous avons toujours
été une opposition constructive qui
cherchent des solutions
un recours a tout de même été déposée
par la liste d'hotman menaceront
engagement trappe citoyen pour invalider
l'élection
[Applaudissements]